الى الخبر العاجل الذي نشاهده على الشاشه
انتشال ناجم من تحت انقاض الزلزال في
اليمن بتركيا بعد نحو 200 ساعه من وقوع
الزلزال على كل نذهب الان الى معبر باب
الهوى انضم الينا من هناك مراسلنا ادهم
ابو الحسام اذا ادهم بانتظار مرور
مرور القرار في مجلس الامن وفتح المزيد من
المعابر كيف يبدو حال المعبر
نترقب حاليا وصول القافله مؤلفه من 32
شاحنه هي قافله امميه وربما ايضا يتبعها
اممي ولكن لم يتثنى لنا التاكد من ذلك حتى
هذه اللحظه
القافله تتضمن مواد اغاثيه وخيام
وتجهيزاتها اللوجستيه اضافه الى سلال
طوارئ وسيلال ايضا نظافه يوميه هذه
القافله تعتبر القافله الثالثه منذ وقوع
الزلزال الذي ضرب منطقه شمال غرب سوريا
كانت قد دخلت قوافل امميه سابقه قافلتين
نتحدث عن مجموع عدد الشاحنات الامميه
قرابه الستين شاحنه ما عدا القاف التي
ستدخل اليوم وايضا دخلت بايام باليومين
الماضيين 30 شاحنه تقريبا من منظمات محليه
ومنظمات اقليميه كان اخرها
ظهر البارحه سبع شاحنات
قطريات تحمل مساعدات طبيه وايضا مستلزمات
واضافه الى يعني معدات ومولدات كهربائيه
قبل دخول هذه القافله دخل وفد قطري مؤلف
من عده اطباء في مختلف التخصصات وهم الان
يزاولون عملهم التطوعي في مختلف
المستشفيات في شمال غرب سوريا هنا ايضا لا
بد من الحديث عن الجانب الاخر من التكافل
الاجتماعي والتضامن نتحدث عن حملات اطلقها
الاهالي في المساجد في المناطق التي كانت
اقل تضررا جراء الزلزال نتحدث عن حملات
ايضا للالبسه تبرعات ماديه نقديه اضافه
الى مساعدات كانت ايضا قد وصلت البارحه
نتحدث عن 150 شاحنه من منطقه دير الزور
دخلت من المناطق الشرقيه باتجاه معبر عون
الدادات ودخلت المنطقه وصولا الى عفرين
جنديرس المنكوبه وايضا تم هذه الشاحنات
بمستودعات
لمنظمات محليه سيشرفون على توزيعها بحسب
الاولويات جميع
المواد التي دخلت خلال الايام السابقه
وبحسب القائمين على العمل الانساني يقولون
انها صحيح انها وصلت متاخره ولكن بدا
الوضع يتحسن قليلا بالنسبه للعوائل
المنكوبه نتحدث عن الاف العائلات المنكوبه
ما زال هناك ايضا الاف العائلات التي لم
تستطع الدخول الى بيوتها ومنازلها حتى هذه
اللحظه ريثما ينتهي تنتهي فرق الدفاع
المدني من مرحله انتشال الضحايا لتنتقل من
بعدها الى مرحله التقييم وفحص البيوت
وجازيتها للسكن ليقرروا فيما بعد ما سيتم
هدمه وما سيتم الاحتفاظ به وترميمه من
جديد هذا هذه المرحله ربما يعني تطول
قليلا لان
يعني مرحله ازاله الانقاض وانتشال الضحايا
ربما تاخذ من عشره ايام الى شهر تقريبا
بحسب فرق الدفاع المدني نحن نتحدث ايضا عن
تقريبا ثلاثين عائله ما زالت تحت انقاض
ركام مدينه جنديرس وايضا الاعمال ما زالت
مستمره في انتشال الضحايا في كل من حارم
وبسنيا
ادهم ابو الحسام مراسلنا من اما معبر باب
الهوى شكرا لك